now dozens of people have reportedly
been killed after an air strike hit a
busy market
in ethiopia's northern tigray region
health workers in the village of tagoga
have told the associated press soldiers
blocked medical teams from reaching the
scene
this attack also happened during some of
the most intense fighting since that
conflict began in november
earlier i spoke to martin plout he's a
visiting senior fellow in the department
of war studies at king's college london
and he says the evidence suggests the
ethiopian air force is responsible
there's frankly nobody else who could
have done it the
eritrean air force is not operating in
the area
the tigrans have no air force who else
could have done it it must have been
an ethiopian jet i don't think that will
come as any surprise to anyone
basically the tigrans have been on the
defensive
ever since the war began in november
they were first driven out of western uh
tigre then they were driven out of the
uh their capital michele
and uh now they have begun to take back
some of the area that they lost uh they
are fighting against both
ethiopian and eritrean forces eritrean
forces you may recall
uh have been coming in from the north
the
ethiopians asked them to leave but they
have so far not done so
and a string of towns have now been
briefly retaken by the uh
the tigrans in a very major offensive
they say they have captured up to 10 000
ethiopian troops now of course that's
not verified
but that's the kind of claim that they
are making that they are now on the
offensive
they've got the they say the ethiopians
on the run
in some areas uh but this is not a war
that's going to be over in five minutes
the last war in this area lasted 17
years this one's been going on seven or
eight months
well let's now speak to hiber morgan she
joins us from gutter reef in sudan near
the border with ethiopia
but the u.n has already declared famine
conditions in parts of tigre and i know
you've
spoken to people who've been forced to
flee there what are you hearing from
them about what the situation on the
ground is like
well first of all let's look at the
location where this airstrike happened
it happened in northwest of makale
that's a place where people will not be
able to escape from to come here
to refugee camps in sudan's godard and
castle states
should they want to that's because of
the location and because of the fact
that ethiopian troops are blocking the
borders so
the number of refugees who are able to
cross here to seek
safety as well as humanitarian
assistance is getting lesser and lesser
uh as time goes by and there are a lot
of people who are displaced already by
the conflict
integra more than 2 million people have
already been displaced
and the u.n is running that more than
350 000 are facing famine
so it is expected that the airstrike
that happened today as well as
uh uh further airstrikes which uh are
expected by
the great um tigran uh rebel forces uh
who say that they will they're expecting
further attacks and that they're also
trying to launch their own offensive to
take some of the areas back
that's expected to result in more
displacement and more people in need of
aid
people in the area are reporting that uh
access of to
health care and to medical assistance
from the airstrike is being blocked
that is a report that uh refugees here
say that
is actually true because they say that
they they can believe that because they
say that they've seen eritrean forces
and ethiopian forces blocking aid
so it looks like the situation integrate
is going to get worse and worse
as the days go by peppa morgan they're
on the ground for us
um in gada reef in sudan near the
ethiopian border thank you so much heber